buongiorno a tutti tissue croft e
l'abbiamo
ap innovativa incubata
ma nell'era
tale e opera nel campo del biomedicale
in particolare si occupa di studiare e
sviluppare dei prodotti innovativi per
la chirurgia dei tessuti molli
questa è un'esigenza che al giorno
d'oggi si pone in maniera imperativa
perché la popolazione sta invecchiando e
un po come succede per le automobili che
dopo un po di anni necessitano di
restyling di sostituzioni di pezzi mal
funzionanti e anche il corpo umano è un
po uno strumento una macchina che col
tempo con gli anni si usura e quindi
necessita in alcuni casi di sostituzione
e quindi si pone in questo ambito il
campo della ricerca che si occupa della
medicina rigenerativa e dell'ingegneria
tissutale a supportare la ricerca
dell'ingegneria tissutale
si apre un campo molto vasto che quello
dei biomateriali i biomateriali sono
materiali che vengono utilizzati
comunemente per studiare protesi
sostituzioni e di conseguenza si possono
utilizzare materiali di varia natura
e qui nella slide vedete che sono
nominate i principali tipi di tessuti
scusate di materiali utilizzati per la
sostituzione di tessuti possiamo avere
materiali di tipo metallico polimerico
ma oggi vi vorrei far concentrare per
pochi minuti sugli ultimi due tipi cioè
i materiali compositi e materiali
biologici
questi hanno grosse affinità lo vedremo
assieme il titolo di questo di questo
tour che l'unione fa la forza e cercherò
di convincervi che in effetti questo
modo di pensare a una base anche
scientifica solida i biomateriali in
generale necessitano di avere proprietà
biologiche e meccaniche adeguate a
sostituire l'organo malfunzionante
quindi ecco che si sceglie la soluzione
adatta per il problema chirurgico
l'utilizzo di materiali compositi in
realtà è qualcosa che per l'uomo non è
nuovo per un attimo muoviamoci dal campo
del biomedicale del chirurgico ma
pensiamo ai ai mattoni di fango e
mattoni di fango sono formati
sostanzialmente da due tipi di materiali
il fango e la paglia separatamente il
fango la paglia hanno delle
caratteristiche che mai ci farebbero
pensare a una struttura solida per
costruire un edificio una casa ma in
effetti se li componiamo assieme
riusciamo ad avere strutture nelle quali
si può addirittura vivere questo è un
tipo molto primitivo di materiale
composito
tuttavia lo è ha le caratteristiche per
essere considerato materiale composito
poi la ricerca nel campo dei materiali
in generale è proseguita fino ai giorni
nostri e prosegue ancora tanto che i
primi materiali compositi cioè mattoni
di fango
adesso abbiamo traslati nel creare
materiali compositi che ci servono a
costruire gli aerei per esempio molto
spesso nella mia esperienza mi è
capitato però di osservare e di trarre
dalle mie osservazioni le conclusioni
per arrivare a una soluzione perché in
realtà i materiali compositi sono
qualcosa di molto presente in natura
vi faccio un altro esempio in legno qui
vedete una sezione di un tronco d'albero
il legno è un materiale composito cioè
c'è una matrice morbida fatta di lignina
ci sono delle fibre che composta insieme
creano quella che la struttura di un
tronco d'albero il corpo umano non si
allontana anche i tessuti sono in fondo
materiali compositi materiali compositi
però appositamente studiati per
risolvere delle funzioni biologiche
specifiche
rimaniamo nell'esempio del tessuto osseo
o si è formato da una componente
minerale dai grossi a patite da una
componente di tipo fibroso che collagene
è in realtà una matrice un pochino più
composita ma per semplificarla uniamo
questi due tipi di materiali e otteniamo
del tessuto osseo tessuto osseo che a
sua volta può avere strutture
microscopiche differenti ma che sono
quelle che ci servono per arrivare al lo
scheletro ultimo io ho fatto un esempio
ne ho parlato di materiale composito in
legno e poi sono passata un altro
esempio in materiale composito il
tessuto osseo e mi è venuto in mente
pinocchio pinocchio è un burattino di
legno
tuttavia senza stare a ritornare a tutta
la storia di pinocchio non era
soddisfatto del suo corpo
il suo essere un burattino di legno non
lo soddisfa va in maniera ottimale
in quel caso è intervenuta la fatina e
l'ha trasformato in un bambino però era
una favola nella realtà quello che
possiamo fare è cercare di aiutare il
nostro pinocchio a trovare delle
soluzioni a partire da tessuti presenti
già in natura da tessuti quindi
biologici il nostro corpo è formato da
un'enorme varietà di tessuti biologici
naturali compositi straordinariamente
ricchi e con una straordinaria efficacia
nel poter arrivare a funzioni biologiche
che ci garantiscono la vita e la
sopravvivenza
io credo che sia un po pretenzioso
pensare di riuscire ad imitare
perfettamente un tessuto a meno che noi
non usiamo il tessuto stesso per poter
riparare il danno che è presente nel
nostro corpo
e allora questa è l'idea alla base di
tissue graf tissue graft usa dei
materiali biologici delle matrici
biologiche le decellularizzato mi toglie
la parte cellulare e non si limita però
questo a seconda della necessità
chirurgica del tipo di utilizzo
chirurgico che si pensa per quella
matrice biologica al richiamo e quindi
poniamo sulla superficie della matrice
delle bio molecole che aiutano per
esempio la rigenerazione tissutale
oppure facciamo un altro esempio se
necessario rendere la superficie di
questo materiale biologico più
resistenti alle infezioni quello che
facciamo è attaccare sulla superficie
della matrice biologica degli
antibiotici questi di cui sentite
parlare in maniera molto molto molto
comune tuttavia questa è soltanto una
delle possibilità che sta alla base del
processo su kraft che è poi il marchio
della startup del start up tv kraft vi
racconto un pochino di più di come è
nata e di quello che siamo diventati
tissue graf nasce a cavallo fra il 2013
e il 2014 quindi non è una realtà
anziana tutt'altro è una realtà molto
giovane e è nata all'interno dell'ambito
universitario insieme ad altri ragazzi
che lavoravano con me
abbiamo iniziato a lavorare su tessuti
decellularizzato e abbiamo pensato che
si poteva arrivare a produrre su un
livello diverso quindi si poteva portare
a livello di produzione industriale
qualcosa che in quel momento stavamo
facendo al bancone per fare questo e
torno al concetto che l'unione fa la
forza
ci siamo resi conto ben presto che
bisognava dare alla nostra idea la
nostra start up un été joan eterogeneità
differente e allora è entrato a far
parte della realtà tissue graf carlo
giani carlo giani si occupa di
amministrare
il patrimonio e le finanze della società
e quindi ci garantisce di poter avere
una serenità
dal punto di vista amministrativo questo
perché io sono biologa e di conseguenza
non potevo inventarmi un altro lavoro e
quindi ho mantenuto la mia identità
scientifica e all'interno del dt show
kraft sono responsabile scientifico dei
prodotti e dei processi che studiamo
insieme a me ci sono altri tre ragazzi
luca fusaro e chimico ed è il ragazzo
che ha pensato in effetti il ricercatore
che ha pensato il processo sin
dall'inizio e tuttora è sua
responsabilità portare avanti i processi
di arricchimento delle matrici martina
ramella e biotecnologo quindi insieme a
me cura la parte più scientifica e di
applicazione dei prodotti che studiamo e
ancora ultimamente s'è unita marta calvo
kato era che invece un ingegnere
l'ingegnere che ha dato una marcia in
più alla nostra idea perché è capace di
progettare il processo di trasferimento
tecnologico
quindi è lei che è capace di dire come
poter passare da un processo al bancone
a un processo industriale
quindi ecco perché la diversità ci rende
forti perché in realtà ognuno di noi ha
un background differente mai di
liberazione che c'è fra noi rende la
startup abbastanza forte e solida io
però circa un anno fa ho sentito la
necessità di trovare un equipe che
potesse aiutare me a garantire il
livello scientifico dei nostri prodotti
e allora a quel punto ho ragionato un po
all'inverso anziché portare l'italia
fuori ho portato all'estero e in italia
e allora ho creato un scientific board
che mi controlla e che valida
quello che noi cerchiamo di
realizzare in laboratorio quindi insieme
a noi ci sono il professor badilate di
pittsburgh dell'università di pittsburgh
la professoressa e linking e la sua
assistente hélène berry e ancora
dell'università di leeds e ancora il
professor diego mantovani non italiano
ma in realtà vive in canada ormai da
diversi anni e ed è un professore
dell'università di laval di quebec city
quindi questa è la realtà
in questo momento tissue croft è nata
pochi anni fa si è rafforzata e si sta
ingrandendo si sta ingrandendo ma la mia
natura accademica mi spinge sempre a
cercare di non allontanarmi troppo da
quello che la mia formazione appunto
universitaria e quindi abbiamo creato
dei posti di dottorato in apprendistato
ce n'è uno attualmente in corso con
l'università di bari e un altro verrà
attivato l'anno prossimo questa volta
con l'università dell'università di
quebec city sono dottorati un po
particolare in apprendistato significa
che lo studente ostra duato e passa metà
del tempo in laboratorio e metà del
tempo in azienda e quindi impara tutta
la parte amministrativa economica che
rende reali le opportunità di creare
un'azienda e inoltre ci saranno presto
anche stage aziendali
che insomma verranno aperti a studenti
anche non anche non di dottorato
un'ultima punto che vorrei sottolineare
tissue graft in effetti è una realtà
fortunata è partita da poco e sta
crescendo in poco tempo però ci siamo
andati a inserire in un ambito di
mercato in forte espansione
questa che vedete una curva che arriva
ai giorni nostri
ma c'è una previsione di forte
espansione anche per i prossimi decenni
quindi questa è stata un po la fortuna
di poter avere l'idea giusta nel momento
giusto
e inoltre questo è un pensiero mio che
viene dall'esperienza al punto
sviluppata in questo settore in questi
anni
credo che le start up siano
un'opportunità per poter creare in
effetti lavoro oggi spesso si sente
parlare di difficoltà di impiego le
difficoltà per i più giovani
ecco nel mio caso è stato una grande
opportunità che mi ha permesso di far
crescere una realtà parallela a quella
universitaria nella quale gli studenti e
anche altri ragazzi di diversa
formazione hanno potuto trovare un
impiego
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]